Jason Momoa has been playing DC's Aquaman for
more than 5 years – but with a new creative
team behind the DC movie machine, rumors are
swirling that he might be about to double-dip.
With anti-heroes like Venom, Deadpool, and
Black Adam making waves at the box office
with their unorthodox methods and off-beat senses
of humor, it's natural to wonder whether some of
the other anti-heroes of the comic book world
are going to get feature films of their own.
Now more than ever, a film centered on
a filthy-mouthed bounty hunter like Lobo
seems like a distinct possibility — if
only an actor can be found to embody
the character's hyper-violent nature
and unusual fondness for profanity.
Who has the x-factor necessary to bring Lobo
from the page to the screen? One obvious choice,
thanks to his experience playing the barbaric
Khal Drogo on "Game of Thrones" is Jason Momoa.
There's only one problem: Momoa is already busy
in the DC Extended Universe playing Aquaman. But
that can't stop fans from dreaming about Momoa
in the role of Lobo, whether or not such an
arrangement would ever be practically possible.
And if you take a look at some recently released
fan art depicting Momoa in the role, you have to
admit he'd make a good fit, and it seems evident
that he'd be able to make the Ultimate Bastich as
entertaining on the screen as he is on the page.
Fans are right to speculate on who might
portray Lobo on the big screen. And Jason
Momoa was recently asked about the possibility in
a ComicBook.com interview to promote his
upcoming "Slumberland" film on Netflix.
James Gunn, set to take over the film wing
of DC Comics, posted a picture of Lobo on
his official Mastodon account, leading
some to assume that a Lobo feature film
is in the works. When asked about it,
Momoa didn't shut down the prospect,
his duties as Aquaman notwithstanding. Having
recently discussed an upcoming "dream project"
within the DC Extended Universe, Momoa doesn't
deny that such a project could involve Lobo:
"Huh. Well, everyone knows I'm a big comic
book fan and so the comic that I collect the
most and I have every comic there is ... you
can do your research and find out what it is."
"I love you too."
Could this be a reference to Lobo? Would
audiences accept two DC superheroes portrayed
by the same actor across multiple projects?
Would Lobo and Aquaman get to fight each other?
None of these questions are answered by the
excellent piece by fan art maestro Bosslogic
on Instagram depicting Momoa as Lobo, but
it looks pretty cool anyway. The picture
shows Momoa in full Lobo gear and makeup,
and the comments seem mostly enthusiastic
about the prospect — even with the Atlantis-sized
conflict of interest the casting would represent.
Bosslogic's rendition of Jason Momoa
in the role of Lobo looks good and
true to the original character. But
it also calls to mind another Jason
Momoa comic book movie project that
never came to fruition: "The Crow."
"The Crow" was famously first adapted for
a movie in the 1990s with Brandon Lee as
the titular gloomy crimefighter,
and for a time, Momoa was attached
to the project. Unfortunately, it didn't
happen, and Momoa even apologized to fans
of the character for his inability
to get the project off the ground.
Looking at Momoa as Lobo in Bosslogic's fan
art, it's difficult not to see the similarities
between both characters' distinctive
facial features, and lament that neither
Momoa's "Lobo" or Momoa's "The Crow" ever made
their way to the screen — at least, not yet.